I wonder if you cut Kojiro If you go against it
, you'll be tattered like the blonde there
.
Yeah,
you need to use someone for your opponent
.
I don't have it in my head You're a
small and light body, but it's a skill aname me
Goodbye is constant
You
're not just a person
It's so nice and how many times
q 2 bodies or
Usa City Be careful I don't like a strong man like
you, ready, stop tag, I'll
be you, what can I
do, what can
I do?
[Music  ]
Wow eyes
ana
wh Don't help me
th
That blonde was crushed in one shot, but
I was caught in such a color gimmick at
5 o'clock old star It was just a little hot water,
but I can not understand the color gimmick
I'm receiving special training as Kofu, so I have to
do it seriously.